milk
release the pot oh oh yes the pie gal
it's time for war now let's go okay
this this video went viral of the
manager of Nell uh John Shahidi
brilliant Guy and um he also has manages
a bunch of other podcasts and he's
involved with some businesses like yeah
like he's connected with Elon and uh
he's just just really really interesting
dude and uh it's been very good to us in
terms of giving advice and that kind of
[__] and so he's on this podcast with I
believe is Graham Stefan's yeah the iced
coffee hour yep right okay so this goes
viral
you guys ever shoot podcasts and not
post them yeah yeah it's a sore subject
but yeah there was one but there was a
episode with Andrew Schultz Schultz went
after like you know I think you know
when like a stand-up comedian like looks
in a crowd and decides like just go
after somebody well I think like Schultz
was kind of like went out to steiny and
he um
and it was pretty awkward was it the
whole episode or was it like it was a
bulk of it it was like no you couldn't
cut around it he would come back to him
like he just wanted to go after Steinman
yep almost felt bad for Steiner okay
that's funny okay now
listen why are you going around I don't
even think it was that long uh oh it's
dying now nelk reacted to this video
because a lot of people are giving them
[__] they're like release the [__]
episode you [__] Etc and they
basically were like
Schultz said he didn't want to put out
the episode yeah which is true
because it sucked yeah yeah yeah it was
like I think I told you guys yeah it was
just like one of the worst podcasts I've
ever been on and and basically
like here's the thing here's what
happened it was
it was Steve will do it who's [__]
hilarious and he's a fan you know he was
even promoted the special he was great
and uh and then Kyle and and steiny and
Kyle is like to Mastermind behind nelp
like he's kind of like a genius so he's
a guy I see the most he just understands
culture and like connecting with
different people and like building a
community and a brand and but Kyle and
steiny
I don't think they really knew who I was
so like I think they were aware of who I
am or was at the time but not really
that aware of the content and not about
yeah not about you as a famous person or
whatever but your comedy your style like
I think that maybe they watch the
special like right before the Pod or
something like that but I think it was
more a situation where it was like okay
this guy's got a big reach on YouTube we
have a big reach on YouTube this can be
a big episode yeah type of thing and
Steve is is the fan Steve is the
sweetest guy in the world like if I
called Steve right now probably and
asked him to like help me move move my
apartment he'd be like I can be there
tomorrow
yeah so but
it can drive the Pod yeah Kyle and
steiny drive the pot right I'm sitting
in this thing and I thought that they
all were like in the same fraternity or
something I'm I wasn't as familiar with
like no but Kyle's kind of like
organized these like internet
Superstars if you will like the Saleem
and like Bradley Martin and like built
like a team and a brand around it but in
my mind they all went to college
together so when I'm there and they're
not really like talking and I'm just
like what is going on right now they
said that in the video they were like we
were nervous because that was the first
time we had ever all done a pod together
it was just Trump and me
the only time they bring out the A-Team
so it was a it was just this like kind
of weird energy and like I pretty early
on realized that like Kyle and Stein
don't really know me right right that
well because the questions they're
asking are like really basic questions
what's an example has anybody ever like
heckled you
and like there's a moment in the pot I
don't know if they edit it but where I'm
like what and they're like like have you
ever like talked to someone in the crowd
and like
so I'm thinking so I'm thinking two
different things in this moment I'm
going either they have no clue who I am
and that's weird that I would even be
here annoying yeah or
they know and it's a troll
so I'm I'm like hmm
do you know what I mean like
like steiny gotta you got Clips
yeah but I don't even think I was being
funny I think I was just you know
explaining to him who I think he is in a
Stern way yeah yeah yeah yeah so
but but you have to understand it was
just like it was like a
I think they even said in the clip it
was like a weird moment the energy was
just kind of off you know and like like
we're just doing the interviewing like
randomly like producers would come in
and like
angle the happy Dad cans like to the
camera so the logo was facing the can
and I'd be like in the middle of like
telling a story or explaining something
like a check drop yeah and I'm like and
I'd be like you hate those yeah exactly
but it was just one of those things
where it's like I'm like I'm in this
moment we're like okay I don't think
these guys know who I am there are
moments where like none of us talked
like we just sit there like this and I'd
be like what is [__] happening right
now so like
uh and then the logo thing and I was
just like it what is it like the
beautiful thing about pockets is when
you have like genuine interest in
someone you get to sit across with them
like ask all your con your questions and
like you know get to the bottom of
theories or if you hate someone yeah you
get to confront them about something
it's like it's just like this beautiful
thing and in the moment where they're
moving the logo I'm like am I doing a
commercial for happy Dad and not getting
paid for it like what is going on right
now so I think they do like a base level
of research like someone is coming out
of their day to like spend time to sit
with you so and God bless Akash we've
had some guests on where he's been like
dude I gotta research this guy yeah
so I think I just I
mean right here
so I think it was just like and then I
think maybe steiny asked me one one more
question and it could have been genuine
from him but it felt like trolling and I
was like who is this [__] Chicken
McNugget asking me [__]
like like who is this what I'm trying to
film a commercial yeah I'm trying to do
a happy
yeah and then they asked me some [__]
question and uh you know
which it is kind of funny that like
Steve I guess doesn't talk that much so
he wasn't saying that much and then Kyle
apparently doesn't always like lead a
lot of times with certain people so he
wasn't talking about the steiny
according to the video his explanation
he was like I was doing my best to like
keep it going he was trying and then he
was leading most of that interview and
it always seems like he was like am I
interviewing y'all yeah like that's the
thing like so afterwards I hit him up I
was like I was like yo should we just
scrap it and then I was just gonna tell
I was and we can like do it again and I
was gonna say bring Bradley and Saleem
we'll have more of a rapport with and
then like they know my stuff a little
bit more and then we can kind of have
some fun even John could have been on
the Pod yeah John should have sat down
so I was just gonna say yeah we could do
it again and then what I heard
was that but I also but they also were
like hey we'll edit it and then see
what's going on and I was like look it's
fine it's your pod whatever you want to
do but then what I heard is that steiny
was like please don't release them
so I think he's acting as if he you know
he's like yeah let's just have it out
there I think they should release it
still like I just put it out I know
they're concerned about Steve will do it
space because I think he's banned from
YouTube but just blur his face like if
you blur his face
sounds like you didn't talk much anyway
so in the beginning mainly you and
steiny in the beginning it was some
talking and I think everybody was like
what is going on right like I've never
seen a podcast people should see it for
what not to do on a podcast like it
there's I hope that you can see there's
a moment well I think we all just take a
breath together this is like there's a
moment yeah where like it's like so you
have a watch cool what did you tell time
with that let's take a break happy that
is coming out of the new flavor chicken
McNuggets you know it's like it was
going on but on right you know what this
reminds me of what this beautiful moment
from Seinfeld and Larry
and he was smart enough to keep it in
yeah oh it's live what a genius
should we watch it you've seen this I
mean it's fantastic this is exactly how
I felt and maybe it went similar 180
episodes you gave it up right I did they
didn't cancel you you canceled them
foreign
[Laughter]
let me just tell you something I was not
that funny
you know what you and Seinfeld is like
you know you hate your dad and then you
just become your dad yeah that's you and
Seinfeld what do you talk I cannot wait
till you guys meet up today it's gonna
be amazing oh we have didn't go well
again again
do you not know who I am it was there
they said something I think the
question's in there it's like it was
something like uh yeah so if you ever
had a situation where like you like
interact with the audience on the fly or
something
I love this stuff
and I think I just feel like this I
think I just went
yeah yeah I think that I think it was
just like yeah and that point I was like
I think he's trolling yeah they had to
pay trolling it it felt like you're just
very unfamiliar
because that's the thing I didn't know
so I chose to be more direct yeah like
he was trolling I don't want to see this
yeah because if you guys aren't familiar
you'd be softer but if you think he's
trolling the only way to beat him is to
and there's a certain level of like you
got to be at a level to troll you know
like if if Charlemagne is trolling me
like that and I'm on The Breakfast Club
it's just a hilarious thing yeah but you
know
I don't think anybody has gone further
in entertainment with less Talent than
this kit so it's like
like where does he get off trolling okay
so that's why I was like I need to this
needs a reaction you're gonna mess if
you're happy that sponsorship dude
you're really gonna mess that up all
that happy that money is going out the
drain right now damn flavor for you what
flavor
[Laughter]
I'm good you've really lost it when
they're like yo how's your time on Guy
Code
you're just graduated so you went to
UCSB what was that literally it felt
like that were you the class clown yeah
honestly it might have been one of the
questions it was like Hey chat GPT can
you give a list of questions for a
comedian that you've never seen before
yeah that that that was the question and
it's just and it's a like
let's just not do it yeah that's good
you know I'd just rather just not do it
I want to see it now put it out guys put
it up it's also hilarious because I
think steiny was trying to keep it
afloat and the fact that genuine in fact
he was the one trying and you just
cooperated yeah
listen if that's the case I apologize if
that's the case I apologize but it he
has like an air of inauthenticity to him
so and like it's always hard for me to
be around people that are like
pretending so it's like I I you know you
know what I mean like my um my knee-jerk
reaction to people who are being fake
with me is to be like incredibly direct
with them so that they have to be real
in that moment you know what I mean
and
you know if he was doing his best and he
was like feeling insecure that the
interview wasn't doing that well and
like he was doing something okay I'm the
only one that'll ask questions yeah then
I Then I then I feel bad and I would
apologize for it that being said it
might be consistent to like how he is
yeah I know the just the overwhelming
hate for this poor kid
it's just unbelievable
it's like he's like catch me outside
or something like it's just
the video went up and like every comment
was like [__] that kid
and maybe he was genuinely trying to
keep the interview well I'm sure you're
gonna help his PR with your I don't know
who's gone further on less Talent
campaign I just believe it but that's
not that doesn't mean he's a bad guy but
it doesn't mean no he's he's he's
socially Savvy I mean he's gotten to
this position right like I think he
started out as Steve's assistant and
then he got now he's on the show and
Steve isn't
like so the kid is socially Savvy
there's no question to get there I think
I even said sit on the Pod but um
I don't know like I I don't know would
you want to come out of its entirety or
the way Kyle was saying it was reacting
to moments and then discussing them
further put it out
yeah
yeah that dead air is what you really
want it's the sweet sauce yeah and it's
also fun to watch it from this
perspective yeah because if you went
into it with the excitement of like
saying you're a fan of the milk boys
you're a fan of us and you're like oh
[__] I want to see shorts on the show
this is going to be this awesome
collaboration of these two people that
I'm really into you're gonna be like
this was the worst thing that's ever
happened but if you go into it going
this is the worst podcast ever and then
it satisfies that you're like hell yeah
nailed it yeah is